looking down from the international
space station divisions on earth seem
insignificant and small
russia has worked collaboratively with
the west on the iss since the end of the
cold war it's a partnership that has
withstood geopolitical tensions before
the station had a wall built around it
that kept it isolated from tensions on
earth
and
that wall seems to be crumbling a little
bit with the inflammatory character of
mr rogozon's comments dimitri rogozan is
the head of the russian space agency he
recently posted a video of partner
country's national flags being removed
from a russian rocket to which former
u.s astronaut scott kelly responded in
russian without those flags in the
foreign exchange they bring in your
space program won't be worth a damn
right now the seven person crew at the
iss is made up of two russians four
americans and one german
but later this month three more russian
cosmonauts are scheduled to arrive at
the iss while an american and two
russians are slated to come home so
seeing how that works if they all get
get back to earth on board the same
rocket ship or not will really determine
um i feel like the fate of the iss when
it comes to this collaboration but there
are already signs that russia is pulling
back the russian space agency announced
over twitter that the state corporation
will not cooperate with germany on joint
experiments on the russian segment of
the iss adding the russian space program
will be adjusted against the backdrop of
sanctions with the priority becoming the
creation of satellites in the interest
of defense
those divisions appear now to be
escaping from the confines of earth
heather urex west global news calgary